[音楽]
ね払うんでぃるっているのか白って誰がいる
やっぱ
動画取りますこれじゃあねー可能であれば j 6だけして
痛い肇社長です皆さんゲーム好きですか牧童脅している人はおおよそ把握してると思う
んですけども僕ゲームがまあそこそこ大好きなんですよ
まにゃんみたいな事は言わないですまにゃとかなんかオタクとまでは言わないですけど
そこまで言っちゃうと長生き杉田専門のみてねこのみると数年が知識とかなら実力がね
駄目だと思うんですけど僕は実力の知識もそうかー倉庫
ない方なんですけども全番手に見た時にゲームが結構好きな方なんで副てきまーゲーム
大好きな人の方だと思うんですけどあの最近のゲームつったらもう年度結構二極化して
おりましててがで喧嘩きれいゲーみたいなところがあるんですけど皆さんゲームキーで
いろいろあると思うんです64とかプレステとか何か色々あると思います一致とか
いろいろある中でどんなけチーズ
第ゲーム機見たことありますでしょうかがれにちゃんとしてってなんかあんぴぺみたい
ななんか白黒ゲームじゃなくてちゃんとしたゲーム機で一番小さい奴は何かなと思って
わかんねこれ僕の世代なら通用すると思うんですけども今の子たちは知ってるかわかん
ないと思うんですけど昔デール鯉ああ馬っていうのがあったんですよ
知らない仕上げ待ってゲームを宿す見なかったらもうすぐジェネレーションギャップが
やばすぎるんですけども知らない人はあったらぐらいのちょっと覚えておいてください
ゲームボーイ後バスっていうのがあったんですそれはそれはもう入りましてあの
ポケモンとかも僕ゲームボーイアドバンス
ルビーサファイヤってやつだったんですけどももなんかもんな
うまく説明できんだよねなんかただ俺の猫
世代20代だ
このゲームやってる人たちはも多分銀小屋アドバンス沿いをやってきた人たちだと思う
んですよこれからちょっとアレなんで重要なポジションを占めでゲーム機ゲームウェア
どますっていうのがあるんですけどもその中でもいろんな音なんかだったんですゲーム
ボーイ後ますというのがありましたぱぱ化できるようになったのがゲームボーイ
アドバンス sp ですがあったんですねさらにそれをめちゃくちゃ小さくしてなんか
もう
ゲーム機の
小ささを限界まで縮めようって売りはれておそらく史上最初に小さいゲーム機がこちら
ゲーム多いミクロでございますじゃあみんな見たことありますでしょうか
mother 1つ入ってるんですけどもう俺の手と比べもこのサイズ感分かりますね
こんなちっちゃいんですよ
スマホと比べてももうこうサイズのさあ23回りぐらい
小さいゲーム機でございますあこれがねぇ
クリーン
いいんですもう無くん誰かわかんないんですけどとレーザーのなんで買ったかっていう
とまあほっちゃんちに行った時に彼がこれやってて
いいなって思いましたこれだけですオサレじゃないですか何か昔年だかオシャレな雑誌
見てるんですけども
おっしゃちゃんとの鞄の中チェックみたいなカバンの中身てみますせるチェックみたい
のやってたら
だから女の子も男の子もものがおしゃれな人はねこれ入ってんだけどカバンの中に
つまり俺はオシャレやもゲームボーイアドバンスってねどんだけ伝説のゲームを残した
ことかも代表作と言ったらもっ
世論もぐっとモンスタールビーサファイアとかあると思いますよ
マジカルバケーションでました嗅ぎ取るブルー青の外でぼぶらーの対応とかやってた
ブロックは n シリーズも行ったクローズいつもいましたねファンタジーシリーズの
復刻で出てますけど6メットミスタードリラーとかネス伝説のスタフィーとをやりまし
たねわからない食べ全然言い足りないほど名作という名作ゲームが出てるんですかと座
ターっていうゲームも楽しかったねそれをこのサイズ感で遊べるのは本当に素晴らしい
ことだなって僕思いました
ちなみにもう売り切れててプレミアでめちゃくちゃ高いですよ本当に聴いてみようない
んで買ったんだろう積んでさーん
ゲームボーイミクロ買った座
あれじゃないくらいだったと思う
よな平和い一番で買ったよ
1ね強くだったからかもしれないません
4万もしたのまあなぜ何が言いたいかっていうとなんかこうスマホゲームはもちろん
楽しんで待つ身だが綺麗なゲームを作るんですけども
1回戻って1回戻って昔のゲームやってみたらなんかめちゃくちゃ懐かしいなと言って
ボツになりましたって話をしたかっただけで気をつけてみましょう
俺めっちゃ画面小さい所 mother 1と2が遊びますにぼグッツ多分人生の中で
一番好きなゲームなんですけど
過去実習ぐらい全クリしておりますしモーターでスパイという感じですねめっちゃ画質
も全然綺麗だしてバリバリ動くんですよ
いいですねオサレですねこういう出たらオッシャレたなって思いますよ
スマホによりこんなに小さい子って全然素晴らしいと思いますあっ
問題はこれが話で最小のゲームなのかどうかんっ
うつでしょ原簿に見切れる小さい順ベッチャーでは悔しい
めっちゃ小さいのあるやんの小さなのをさすがにこれは小さすぎじゃねってくらい
小さいですねぼく体でかい多分これ以上ぞ
小さくなると多分無理ですゲームができませんってなるとやっぱり事実こいつが世界
最強ってことなんじゃないでしょうか
とりあえず何が言いたいかっていうと加工いろんなゲームやってきたんですけどまた
らしいゲームはもちろん
いいですよブースでいいなと思うし面白いんですけどやっぱりこういう自分を作った
ゲームなんですよ現場やトランスのいろんなゲームで震災が目にできるのは本当に素敵
なことだなって思いますやマナーは神ゲオ行ったほうがいいし本当にオシャレよ
こんな隊では今後サイズ4幸あれ的だ
あれスネークが出てきたわー4 c
んこれは今ず真相がヤバいなんでならムカデに曲げることあるそこら辺にぃちゃん
真っ赤でに負けそうですねで2万人寒風に負けて聞いてるんだよっぱ
田面し合ったん
me
あっはい